cuando en las siguientes funciones es
impar y aquí tenemos las gráficas de las
funciones recordemos brevemente que una
función es impar una función es impar si
solos y para todo a efe de a
efe de menos
están relacionadas como que esta idea es
el negativo de efe de menos a o que f de
menos a es el negativo df de a
cualquiera de esas dos condiciones es
equivalente y esto tiene que valer para
todo valor
entonces por ejemplo empecemos con fx y
consideremos efe de dos entonces aquí
tengo efe de dos y parece que f de dos
vale pues algo así como 2
y que hay df de minutos efe 2 ya estoy
aquí y por acá tengo que efe de menos 2
parece ser igual a 6 claramente 6 no es
igual a menos 2 o 2 no es igual a menos
seis así que fx no puede ser impar fx no
fue impar bien continuamos que hay deje
de x pues ahora si yo pongo digamos aquí
me fijo en lo que vendría siendo g de 2
entonces tengo kg de 2 es igual a menos
pero cuánto es gd -2 pues de nuevo
parece ser menos 7 g de menos 2
es igual a hay ese método el espacio -7
de hecho esto parece pasar para
cualquier punto x que nos tomemos para
cualquier punto x parece que la función
tome el mismo valor en menos x por lo
tanto como gx parece ser igual a gd
menos x
para todo x entonces gx es una función
par o impar por lo tanto gx tampoco fue
impar sólo nos queda hdx así que más
vale que ésta sea antes que nada noten
que si yo aquí escribo efe de cero
entonces tengo que f cero tiene que ser
igual a menos f de menos cero pero
cuanto es menos cero pues simplemente
cero así que efe de cero es igual a
menos efe de cero por lo tanto
efe 0 tiene que ser igual a 0
así que la función tiene que pasar por
el origen y está funcione efectivamente
pasa por el origen ahora bien si yo
considero cualquier punto por ejemplo
aquí en uno
el 1 parece estar a esta altura a su
función y en -1 la función parece estar
más o menos a la misma distancia del eje
x pero ahora hacia abajo del eje x por
ejemplo también podría tomarme aquí la
función en menos 4 y en menos 4 está
esta magnitud hacia arriba del eje x
pero en 4 que sería menos menos 4 la
función parece estar a la misma magnitud
sólo que ahora hacia abajo por lo tanto
esta función sí parece ser impar además
de que si pasa por el origen noten que
las funciones pares como ésta tienen
simetría alrededor del eje vertical y
las funciones impares lo que tienen es
como si primero reflejara alrededor del
eje vertical y luego reflejará alrededor
del eje horizontal pero la forma más
fácil es simplemente checar que
efectivamente para cualquier punto que
yo me tomé por ejemplo aquí el 8
entonces
efe de 8 parece estar a esta magnitud
hacia arriba del eje x mientras que f de
menos 8
está a la misma magnitud pero por debajo
del eje x así que esta función es impar
hdx
impar
por lo tanto la función que buscamos es
hd x